to conference together because
Firmin
instability pushing for
against
[Music]
the same will and the same determination
and the same desire for unity thank you
well I want to thank you very much and I
think more importantly than anything I
wanted to come up here to say that
because the job that president McCrone
and and your wife by the way who is a
great lady
Brigid would like to thank Bridget she
has been spectacular spent a tremendous
amount of time with Melania and some of
the folks who came in some of the wives
that came in and they had a great tour
of the area and it's a beautiful area
but I want to thank you very much mr.
president for the incredible job you did
this is a truly successful g7 there was
tremendous unity there was great unity
sometimes that read a little bit of
false reporting and I will tell you
there was in fact we were we would have
stayed for another hour
nobody wanted to leave we were
accomplishing a lot but I think more
importantly we were getting along very
well seven countries and it really was
the g7 and you have been a spectacular
leader on this and I want to thank you
and I want to thank the great country of
France thank you very much
after that I think I got you I was go
ahead let's go you know I I just wanted
to say we would think to question okay
each side after what I will say goodbye
to my friends Rising Sun I will give
them you know for you to follow up with
if you like we could do two each and
then we believe the Rose would you
prefer that or would you prefer to I
just don't want to have the President or
friend standing here well I'm answering
these absolutely wonderful questions
okay
so why don't we start with a question
for friends she's four questions - how
about g7 and the u.s. ranko relations um
and Emmanuel is gonna have his own press
conference after this okay so that'll be
fine go ahead
two friends John good friends thank you
my god of course they of those Michigan
person from China was not on the
official agenda but it was certainly a
big part of the discussions here at the
g7 are you concerned that the trade war
that exists now between the United
States and China could harm the global
economy if you are did you talk to
President Trump about that and are you
also at the same time concern that if
China's current trade practices bill
unchecked that a decade from now we
could be in a very terrible situation we
obviously had lengthy discussions you
all let's assume fuel economy resolution
on the world economy yesterday morning
so with this using on both subjects
discussions underway in China and the
United States okay clearly see which
disturb mark during the negotiation
tensions which is the case of any
discussion these are different markets
now the question is to know what the
result of discussions what abating sums
that that she reversed why they cannot
go we said what we
said that it was so important an
agreement to be taken in between the two
greatest the world in Tirana clearly
showed us his arrival we saw just a few
hours message from this we see the
things I'm sweetie can I go art is
turning tricks because I think there
will be something positive for everyone
that's really nice it has to be a
balanced agreement that will be good for
everyone in that context our different
parameters will be taken on one of the
world that's the American presidents
wish in terms of trade I said this earth
my lemon for me most effective way II
and the most strategic way of ignition
and settling our trade relations is to
develop to ensure that trade is part of
international trade rules for the
problems we sometimes have a good
economy very familiar major economy
where there's been lots of us tea and
from European countries Canada and Japan
respecting intellectual property
capacity dealing with excess capacity
which sometimes unbalances ability to do
rapidly with confidence we may have
situations when this type of trade
outside of WTO Broz things don't work
very well
the WTO rules has allowed us to be
protected on that subject
so what we decided together yesterday
accelerate so that everyone can have
free and read balanced dress I've just
mentioned international friends we wish
to change different context that were
putting forward a little goals and to my
way of thinking the way to deal with the
practices and also the renewal of our
international trade rules as we said
yesterday are you satisfied with how far
the proposed WTO reforms will go you
know that we're getting there just
answer that or do you believe that China
is is sincere about what it said this
morning well you think that they are
just trying to calm the markets and play
for time because our sister network the
Fox Business never has been told by
Chinese sources that they have no plans
I'm going back to where they were in
terms of the negotiations this spring on
intellectual property force technology
transfer ownership so we'll see yeah you
trust that they are sincere I do I think
I want to make a deal very badly I think
that was elevated last night very late
in the night I see an alert or you would
call it breaking news and it was that
the vice chairman we're not talking
about somebody from China at a low level
the vice chairman of China came out that
he wants to see the deal made he wants
it to be made under calm conditions uber
calm I agree with him on that and China
has taken a very hard hit over the last
number of months you know they've lost
three million jobs it'll soon be much
more than three million
their chain is breaking the prayer chain
is breaking up like nobody seen before
and once that happens it's very hard to
put it back together you understand I
think they want very much you want to
make a deal and the longer they wait the
harder it is to put it back if it can be
put back at all so I believe they want
to do a deal the tariffs have hit them
very hard in a fairly short period of
time the United States will have
collected over 100 billion dollars in
tariffs and I say it again the reporters
fail to the media fail to acknowledge it
but if you look at the goods coming in
from China with something about China
not other countries if you look at the
goods they have a power that others
don't have but that power is only good
for so long they've manipulated their
currency they've devalued their currency
and they put a lot of cash into the
system and because of that the prices
have not gone up or if they've gone up
it's been very little because they want
to keep people working if the prices go
up they're not gonna be able to keep
people working they're not gonna be able
to compete it's a brilliant market it's
a brilliant brilliant market the world's
market a lot of markets are brilliant
and frankly I think that China cannot I
don't know maybe they can maybe they
can't I don't think they can do that and
I think they're very smart and I think
President Xi is a great leader who
happens to be a brilliant man and he
can't lose 3 million jobs in a very
short period of time and that's going to
be magnified many times over and it's
going to break down the Chinese system
of Trade and he can't do that so when
you say do you think they want to maybe
they want to and maybe they don't but I
think they want to make a deal I'm not
sure they have a choice and I don't say
that is a threat I don't think they have
a choice in the meantime of the United
States which has never collected 10
cents from China well in a fairly short
period of time be over 100 billion
dollars in tariffs so I think they want
to make a deal
very badly second question let me
through please you don't Matt your
question mr. president you've just
declared
you created the conditions for a
mediator in that and in terms of oil in
exchange sectors and by the United
States v had to fold also reopening
economically which was good for around
short comics French negotiators in
thirteen determined and France was we
considered we needed a guarantee and
Trump during his campaign made a
commitment more demanding and tougher
because he considered this Agreement was
insufficient which cause of the
sanctions may Trump T ran in a country
is having serious consequences and a
serious slow demo and that situation
very clearly the positive side of things
say from one stem is creating pressure
so the two girls that we have discussed
in terms of security on the other hand
we can do that I want us to go further
in this proposals have to be a meeting
between the Americans and I would wish
that no weeks such a meeting take place
left horse and France together with the
other signatory cpoe who are our
partners too clearly but after that will
necessary more conditions what you have
the necessary visibility for this
agreement to be signed into the place
and for this meeting I would rather talk
about concerted
and exchanges rather than mediation
exchanges with to get there I want to
have showed himself to be open this
meeting happening and President Johnson
believes that he's being demanding he's
been put forward sanctions but I'm ready
to have a meeting to make an agreement
the United Kingdom with Germany and all
the other signatory powers and the
permanent members of the Security
Council Iran is a country that is not
the same country that it was
two-and-a-half years ago when I came
into office Iran was the number one
state of terror throughout the world
there were 18 sites of confliction in my
first week when I spoke with the folks
at the Pentagon including lots of
generals and lots of other military
experts 18 sites of confliction meaning
18 sites of big problems every one of
them was backed by Iran or in some cases
actually using Iranian soldiers but at a
minimum Iranian wealth much of it given
and the ridiculous deal where they were
given a hundred and fifty billion
dollars plus one point eight billion
dollars in cash and they use that money
for some bad purposes with that being
said I think that a LAN is a country of
tremendous potential we're not looking
for leadership change we're not looking
for that kind of change this country has
been through that many times before that
doesn't work we're looking for no
nuclear weapons no ballistic missiles
and a longer period of time very simple
we can have it done in a very short
period of time and I really believe that
Iran can be a great nation I'd like to
see that happen but they can't have
nuclear weapons okay thank you excuse me
if these circumstances were correct or
the right I would certainly agree to
that but in the meantime they have to be
good players you understand what that
means and they can't do what they were
saying they're going to do because if
they do that they're going to be met
with really very violent force would
have no choice so I think they're going
to be good I really think they'd like to
and by the way president McCrone told me
every step that he was making yesterday
a lot of you said oh he came in and he
told me long before he came in what was
happening what was I didn't think it was
appropriate to meet yesterday too soon
and things have to be worked out first
but president McCrone tell me exactly
what was happening who was coming what
time they were coming where they were
going to meet and after the meeting he
told me exactly what happened and I
think he had a very positive meeting
Prime Minister Robi of Japan also a
large purchaser of oil from Iran he was
also very much involved and you know he
knows everybody there so he was a very
very positive force but I have to tell
you the president's done an excellent
job and we're going to see how it all
turns out maybe it works maybe it
doesn't I say all the time about
everything maybe it works and maybe it
doesn't but I'll tell you what we made a
ridiculous deal we gave 150 billion in
1.8 billion and we got nothing we got
nothing and by the way that agreement
was so short term then it expires in a
very short period of time with a country
you don't make a deal that sure
countries last for long times and you
know do short term deal especially when
you're paying that kind of money so I
have good feelings about Iran I have
good feelings that it'll work I know
many Iranians living in New York City
have million friends from Iran they're
incredible people incredible people
so the last thing I'd like to see is a
big problem but we have to do what we
have to do okay go ahead no no no you
first
no no yes it's
Thank You president McCrone did you did
you seek president Trump's permission
before you invited foreign minister
zarif or did you simply inform him that
he was coming thanks for his precise
questions to be very clear and and we we
are part of GT Buick
we decided to remain as a still so we
are very much interested by the
situation as a sovereign country that's
why we want different parties to move on
the other side as president Trump made
it very clear over the summer we never
spoke on behalf of other countries
we just tried tested some solutions and
to see if we can find an agreement with
different countries so we took an
initiative this summer to make a
proposal a technical one I got the
reaction from Iran's who president Zarif
visits on Friday and Friday morning in
Perth after the discussion we had at the
g7 dinner on Saturday evening I thought
that it was very clear about where we
can go together so the day after I
decided to invite as friends Minister
Zarif so I informed before making it I
informed present that it was my idea not
to involve the United States not to say
this is on behalf of you of everybody
same as friends I think it would be a
good idea to ask him to go back and try
to negotiate something separately so I
did it on my own I informed before
making it president front it was
informed at each minute about the
solution the situation sorry and the
idea for me was in case of circular move
and important move and appropriate
solutions perhaps to have meetings
between ministers another president runs
over because
written from florals present Pony so
this is my precise answers this is a
French initiative but made by a clear
information of the US president before
information as well of the the three
Europeans and its fauna in from present
something although to move across the
situation and to approach it together is
something more was adapted I have to say
the jcpoa was a a deal should not have
been entered into a lot of things could
have happened that would have been much
different they're allowed to test
ballistic missiles you're not allowed to
go to various sites to check and some of
those sites of the most obvious sites
for the creation or the making of
nuclear weapons and those things have to
be changed and other things have to be
changed and i will tell you i have very
good feelings about it i think that
we're going to do something there may
not be immediately but i think
ultimately we're gonna do something as
they said iran is a much different
country than it was doing they have
years ago and we can get that back and
i'd encourage it i actually have friends
years ago many years ago they were in
the real estate business said they were
iran and they were building houses and
building housing and building office
buildings and apartment houses and they
did very well they made a lot of money
and to this day they're not exactly the
youngest developers anymore I tell you
they were young when they went over
there they made a lot of money and they
love the people and they loved what was
going on and it's a country with
tremendous potential I also say that by
the way with respect to North Korea Kim
Jong hoon who had gotten to know
extremely well first lady has gotten to
know Kim jong-un and I think she did
agree with me he is a man with a country
that has tremendous potential you're in
between China Russia and South Korea
people want to get the South Korea they
got to get there somehow and if
do anything other than essentially fly
they want to go through so railroads and
everything else so many things want to
happen there I think that North Korea
has tremendous economic potential and I
think that kim jongwan sees that he
would be the leader and i think he sees
the tremendous potential that it's got
with respect to around the same thing
iran is incredible people an incredible
country potentially location that's a
little rough neighborhood but eventually
it's going to be a beautiful
neighborhood I think that it's going to
be I think it's going to work out
and I really believe that those
countries that went into the original
deal that more and more are agreeing
with what I did
but I think those countries are going to
be saying thank you someday I hope
they're going to be saying implement
France including the president because I
think we did the right thing I know we
did the right thing if for no other
reason it's just too short it's almost
expiring if you think about it and
somebody said well you'll go and make an
extension no no they great negotiators
look at what they did to get the deal
look at what they did to John Kerry and
to President Obama look what happened
with a bringing plane loads of cash
plane loads big planes 757s Boeing 757s
coming into loaded up with cash what
kind of a deal is that so I think a lot
of good things are going to happen and I
just want to say this because I've
spoken a lot with the president this
last two and a half days we've never had
a better relationship we had a lunch
that lasted for quite a while that many
of you got to see who's the two of us no
staff no anything he wasn't trying to
impress his people I wasn't trying to
impress his people we were just trying
to impress each other and I'll tell you
what it was the best period of time
we've ever had and we accomplished a lot
I don't mean just she was wasn't that
nice he's a very capable man he's doing
a great job for France he did an
incredible job for the g7 and I just
want to thank you and you go ahead to
your news
conference and very special this is a
very special very unified two and a half
days ago I thank you for thank you thank
you thank you I will leave the floor and
the person in front stoop risen [ __ ]
and I will end the and wait for the end
of your own press conference you're the
first lady drink a glass of French wine
yesterday so can you give up on your
threat to put sanctions on French wines
because if we've understood correctly
you have arrived at an agreement on
taxing digital firms could you confirm
that there has been an agreement between
you and France on taxing digital I can
confirm that the first lady loved your
French wine okay all right you loved
your French one so thank you very much
that's fine okay
thank you thank you yes Yahoo I will
wait for the end of this press
conference two of the personal part of a
presidency I believe in the problem
thank you this is worse than you are
on China you have recently been saying
that China wants to make a deal but that
you are not necessarily I will start now
please sit down thank you thank you
you've recently q very much you've
recently been saying that China wants a
deal but you're not necessarily ready
for a deal and you like the tariff
revenue that is coming in are you now
ready to make a deal
only if it's a fair deal and a good deal
for the United States otherwise I will
not make a deal we have billions and
billions coming in and I think we're
going to get there I do I believe it
more strongly now that I would have
believed that a while ago we're gonna
get there and we're gonna have a really
would have a fair deal remember this
will you say fair China's been taking
out of this country five hundred plus
billion dollars a year for many many
years many many years it was time to
stop as a private person I used to talk
about it's one of the reasons I'm
president and we're in a great position
our country is doing well our
unemployment numbers are the lowest
they've been in over 50 years our
unemployment numbers for a particular
african-american Asian or Hispanic are
the best they've ever been historic
numbers we're in a very strong position
our consumers are strong Walmart just
announced numbers that were I mean
mind-boggling numbers it's a great poll
right there that's the ultimate poll how
the retailer is doing and how a certain
certain companies doing so we're doing
very well and I think that I think we're
gonna make a deal with China and I think
we'll probably eventually we're gonna
make a deal with Iran too it's not a
question of behavior I think they want
to make a deal and I think they should
make a deal and I think if they don't
make a deal
it's gonna be very bad for China and I
very much appreciate the fact that they
came out last night very late last night
and they said you know they want to make
a deal they want it to be under calm
circumstances
a little different kind of a statement I
thought it was a beautiful statement
here we go for you on next year's g7
summit but can I just clarify someone
you said you mentioned earlier today you
talked about with China and a breaking
news alert him to understand what
specifically we heard from China and on
next year's g7 you alluded today drop
several hints about Miami about Doral
and hosting next year's g7 at your
property what reassurances if any can
you give the American people that you
are not looking to profit off the
presidency well I'll tell you what I've
spent and I think I will in a
combination of loss and opportunity
probably will cost me anywhere from
three to five billion dollars to be
president and the only thing I care
about is this country couldn't care less
otherwise I wouldn't have done it people
have asked me what do you think it costs
and between opportunity not doing thing
I used to get a lot of money to make
speeches now I give speeches all the
time in order to get zero and that's
good and I did a lot of great jobs and
great deals that I don't do anymore I
don't want to do them because the deals
are making a great deals for the country
and that's gonna be much more important
Doral happens to be within Miami it's a
city it's a wonderful place it's a very
very successful area Florida
it's very importantly only five minutes
from the airport the airport is right
next to her it's a big international
that put one of the biggest in the world
everybody that's coming all of these
people with all of their big entourage
is come it's set up so per and by the
way my people looked at 12 sites all
good but some were two hours from an
airport some were four hours from I mean
it was so far away some didn't allow
this so they didn't allow that with
Doral we have a series of magnificent
buildings we call them bungalows they
each hold from 50 to 70 very luxurious
rooms with magnificent views we have
incredible conference rooms incredible
restaurants it's like it's like such a
natural we wouldn't even have to
the work that they did here and they've
done a beautiful job they've really done
a beautiful job and what we have also is
Miami and we have many hundreds of acres
so that in terms of parking in terms of
all of the things that you need the
ballrooms are among the biggest in
Florida and the best it's brand new and
they want that my people wanted it from
my standpoint I'm not gonna make any
money in my opinion I'm not gonna make
any money I don't want to make money I
don't care about making money if I want
to make money I wouldn't worry about the
five billion because that's what I mean
at some point I'm gonna detail that and
we'll show but I think it's just a great
place to be I think having it in Miami
is fantastic really fantastic having it
at that particular place because of the
way it's set up each country can have
their own when I say they have a lot of
units in them so I think it just works
out well and well my people came back
they took tours they went to different
places I won't mention places but you'll
have a list because they're going to
give a presentation and fairly soon they
went to places all over the country and
they came back and they said this is
where would like to be now we had
military people doing it we had Secret
Service people doing it we had people
that really understand what it's about
it's not about me it's about getting the
right location I think it's very
important Jonathan Thank You mr.
president president McCrone said he'd
like to see talks between you and
President rouhani within weeks
does that sound realistic to you could
you see your success in talks with the
Iranians with it well I don't know the
gentlemen I think that I think I know
I'm a little bit just by watching over
the last number of years what's happened
tell me one thing is a great negotiator
but he I think he's gonna want to me I
think Iran wants to get this situation
straightened out now is that based on
fact or based on gut that's based on gut
but they want to get this situation
straightened out Jonathan and they're
really hurting badly their inflation as
you know because I saw your reporting on
it their inflation is through the roof
the economy is tanked
entirely the sanctions are absolutely
hurting them horribly I don't want to
see that I don't want to see that
they're great people I don't want to see
that but we can't let them have a
nuclear weapon can't let it happen so I
think that there's a really good chance
that we would meet Jeff please Thank You
mr. president
another follow-up from what the
president of France said he said that
there might be a need for compensation
to Iran would you given all of the
criticism you've made of the jcpoa and
the money that they got be open to
giving Iran compensation if it met some
of the criteria that you know what he's
talking in terms of compensation is they
are out of money and they need they need
a short term letter of credit or loan no
we're not paying we don't pay but they
may need some money to get them over a
very rough patch and if they do need
money certainly and it would be secured
by oil which to me is great security and
they have a lot of oil but it's a good
deal so we're really talking about a
letter of credit type facility us are
from it would be from numerous countries
in numerous countries and it comes back
it would be it would expire it would be
paid back immediately
and very quickly yes go ahead please yes
thank you very much mr. president
no it's Emma with the Asahi Shinbun
Japanese newspaper just left now the U
Prime Minister okay and the you the US
and Japan has had an agreement in
principle which you said is a tremendous
trade deal for the United States so so
are you still considering imposing
section 232 tariffs on Japan's although
exports to the United States on national
security grounds not at this moment no
well that's one of the reasons we made
the deal but no not at this moment it's
something I could do at a later date if
I wanted to but we're not
then we just want to be treated fairly
you know Japan has had a tremendous
trade surplus with the United States for
many many years long before I came here
and I'll tell you something we're
transforming our country we're taking
these horrible one-sided foolish very
dumb stupid if you'd like to use that
word because it's so descriptive we're
taking these trade deals that are so bad
and we're making good solid deal side of
them and that's transforming our country
that's that will be transformative and
very exciting I think for a country very
very exciting please go ahead Thank You
mr. president
well I didn't actually say you I said
the woman behind you so why don't we do
her first you've been asking a lot of
questions all day long thanks my
surprise me she'll say I don't give you
access right thanks mr. president
Michel Thunder a PBS news hour yes it's
appropriate to invite Russia to the g7
given that they've met within the 2016
election you know are you worried that
if Russia does come to the g7 that it
might hurt you politically because it's
only going to be a couple months before
the 2020 election I don't care
politically a lot of people don't
understand this I ran one election and I
want happened to be for president
I don't care politically I'm gonna run
another election I think I'm winning
based on polls that we see whether I win
or not I have to do the right thing so I
don't do things for political reasons is
it good probably not maybe it is I mean
a lot of people are smart a lot of
people say having Russia which is a
power having them inside the room is
better than having them outside the room
by the way there were numbers people
doing the g7 that felt that way and we
didn't take the vote oh and I think what
we did discuss it my inclination is to
say yes they should be in they were
really it was a president of I'm not
blaming him but a lot of bad things
happened with President Putin and
President Obama one of the things that
happened was as you know what happened
in with a very big area a very very big
and important area in the Middle East
where the red line was drawn
then President Obama decided that he was
not going to do anything about it you
can't draw red lines in the sand you
just can't do it and the other was in
Ukraine having to do with a certain
section of Ukraine that you know very
well where it was sort of taken away
from President Obama not taken away from
President Trump taken away from
President Obama President Obama was not
happy that this happened because it was
embarrassing to him right it was very
embarrassing to him and he wanted to
rush it to be out of the what was called
the g8 and that was his determination he
was outsmarted but I quote he was that
smart and President Putin outsmarted
President Obama looming and I couldn't
understand how President Obama would
feel he wasn't happy and they're not in
for that reason now I'm only thinking
about the world that I'm thinking about
this country in terms of the g7 whether
it's g7 g8 I think it would be better to
have Russia inside the tent then outside
the tent do we live by the way yes we
live by the way is it politically
popular for me to say that possibly not
I think a lot of people would agree with
me frankly but possibly not
I do nothing for politics and a lot of
you aren't going are you gonna smile at
that I do nothing for politics I do
what's right and people like what I do
and but I just do what's right if I
wanted to go strictly by politics I'd
probably poll that and possibly I'd say
oh gee I don't want I don't want Russia
in but I really think it's good for
security of the world it's good for the
economics so they would remember they're
building a big pipeline in Europe going
right up to Germany and I said to I'm
gonna go I had a great relationship but
I said you know you pay Russia billions
of dollars and then we defend you from
Russia statement that Russia outsmarted
President Obama other countries have
said that the reason why Russia was
kicked out was very clearly because they
annex Crimea why keep repeating what
some people would see as a clear lie
well it was an extreme president I know
you like President Obama but it was
annexed during President Obama's
if it was annexed doing my termite say
sorry folks I made a mistake sorry folks
President Obama was helping Ukraine
Crimea was annexed during his term now
it's a very big very very important area
Russia has its submarine that's where
they do their submarine work and that's
where they dock large and powerful
submarines but not as powerful as ours
and not as large as ours but they have
their submarines and President Obama was
pure and simply outsmarted they took
Crimea during his term that was not a
good thing it could have been stopped
could have been stopped with the right
whatever it could have been stuff but
President Obama was unable to stop it
and it's too bad as the g7 host next
year you were allowed to invite other
countries to come guest countries even
though they're not necessarily part of
the overall group would you consider
inviting Vladimir Putin stances he was a
part of g8 and all of a sudden he's not
outdoor it's not in so I think John
actually that's a pretty tough thing for
him you know he's a proud person when I
invite him I would certainly invite him
whether or not he could come
psychologically I think that's a tough
thing for him to do you have a g8 now
it's a g7 and you invite the person that
was thrown out really by President Obama
and really because he got outsmarted
President Obama pure and simple and
don't forget it was not just Crimea it
was the red line in the sand and Obama's
had never violated the red line in the
sand and then they went ahead and they
killed many children with gas it was
terrible and he did nothing about it I
did but I was there years later I did
something about it but I was there legs
thank you sir
can you help us understand the timeline
on the China calls were you referring to
the statement by the place we've had
many calls or secretary minuchin is here
and you've had many calls over the last
24 hours but certainly over the last 48
hours we've had many calls not just one
this isn't one and these are high-level
calls they want to make a deal and by
the way I think it was gonna be made but
they want to make a deal so the Chinese
are saying that there weren't any DJs
and that's saying something the vice
chairman of China you get higher than
that other than President Xi the vice
president the vice chairman [ __ ] the
vice president the vice chairman made
the statement that he wants to make a
deal and he wants to see a comment mr.
he wants it all to happen that says it
there I don't have to talk about you
know you folks who were reporting before
well we can't find any phone call he
released a statement I didn't really
said he released his statement but there
were phone call sir with numerous calls
and not only was Steve there were calls
with other people too just so you
understand China wants to make a deal
now whether or not we make a deal it's
gotta be a great deal for us you know
and I told us the president she who I
really respect I really do have great
respect and I like him too
he's a tough guy but I have a lot of
feeling for president she's very
outstanding in so many ways but I told
the very strong I said look you're
starting up here and you're making five
hundred billion a year and stealing our
intellectual property we down on the
floor lower than the floor fifty-fifty
this has to be a deal that's better for
us and if it's not better let's not do
business together
I don't want to do business to get about
tariffs for a second we're taking in
tremendous amounts of money forget that
I don't do business now when I raised
and he raises I raise it here it we can
never catch up we have the balance our
trading relationship at least to an
extent and they were unwilling to do
that and we'll never have a deal if that
happens but it's gonna happen because
they have to have a deal and as far as
phone calls are concerned secretary of
the treasury and other people have been
receiving many calls not receiving back
and forth many calls China wants to make
a deal and if we can we will make a deal
mr. president I could ask you a little
bit about your China strategy this
president McCrone talked a little bit
about instability and the worry in the
markets and in around the globe about
instability one of the things that that
comes from as you talk to me about
global economic instability because from
is the back and forth and the changing
statements from yourself so that sorry
negotiated so my question is is that a
strategy is it a strategy is called
President Xi an enemy one day and then
say their relations are very
you know she ate it's done very well for
me over the years and it's doing even
better for the country I think and I do
think that look is the story I have
people say oh just make a deal make a
deal they don't have the guts and they
don't have the wisdom to know that you
can't continue to go on where a country
is taking 500 billion that million five
hundred million with a be out every
single year five hundred billion dollars
you just can't do that somebody had to
do this they should have been done by
President Obama it should have been done
and Biden sleepy Joe it should have been
done by other people that should have
been done lovely he should have been
done by Clinton double bush should have
been done I'm doing it let me tell you
something else North Korea should have
been done a long time ago I'm doing it
I'm doing a lot of things that I
shouldn't have to be doing please go
ahead please
a path Rigby Sky News President Trump
you've met our new Prime Minister Boris
Johnson yesterday yes you said he was
the right man for the job
on brexit I believe there do you think
Theresa May was the wrong woman and do
you think that Boris Johnson can
actually get a deal with the EU before
October the 31st oh well Teresa was
unable to do the deal
I gave her my ideas as to doing to deal
very early on that you possibly know
what they are but I would have done that
she chose to do it her way and that
didn't work out so well I think she's a
very very good person and a good woman
and I really believe that Boris Johnson
will be a great prime minister you know
we like each other and we had a great
two and a half days I've been waiting
for him to be Prime Minister for about
six years I told them what took you so
long I think he's going to be a great
Prime Minister and especially after
spending a lot of intense time with him
over the last couple of days he's really
he's very smart he's very strong and
he's very enthusiastic and you know what
else he loves you a country he really
loves you a country that came out maybe
more than anything else yeah please
Vickie young BBC News President Trump
Boris Johnson is very keen on a trade
deal with the USA
you sound keen on it to some of his
critics that'll bird that you're gonna
do over the UK property in the UK I love
the UK I have no idea how my property is
doing because I don't care but I own
Turnberry and I own an Aberdeen and I
own and Ireland as you know
and great stuff and I'll be honest with
you I think I think that I think he's
gonna just do a great job as Prime
Minister you know it takes a lot it's so
many different elements to being a great
Prime Minister and you needed him I just
think his time is right this is the
right time for Boris this is the right
time for Boris yep let's go see who
you're with Blake Robinson from ITV in
the UK as well you've obviously had a
good few days with President Mackel
oh you appear to be doing business with
it that's your favorite expression after
brexit who do you think will be your
more important relationship president
Michel France and the EU or Boris
Johnson Prime Minister the United
Kingdom I think we're gonna have just
look France is a great nation it's being
run a lot of things that happening you
know it's not easy what he's doing he's
changing certain ways it's a very hard
thing to do I won't get into it I'm
gonna let him sell his ideas but a lot
of people don't disagree with his ideas
but it's a very hard thing to do if
you're a great citizen of French you
love your country but you want to do the
way you've been doing it for a long time
but maybe that's not working and maybe
they have to do what he has to do I
think he's gonna do a fantastic job but
it's very tough for him I know how tough
it is for him he's been having a hard
time and nobody would have an easy time
but I do believe he's doing the right
thing and Boris is different it's a
different kind of a deal boris has to
try and do something with Brexton
it's very tough I deal with the EU the
EU is that's a very very strong group of
people they have their ideas and they're
not easy to deal with I will tell you
we're very close to making a deal by the
way with the EU I have to say this we've
made a great deal with Japan and we're
very close to maybe making a deal with
the EU because they don't want tariffs
it's very simple they don't want tax
cars Mercedes Benz BMW in or need a 20%
or 25% tax we're very close I think
we're gonna make a deal with EU
without having to go that route I didn't
have to go that route but maybe not
we're gonna have a deal a really fair
deal but the EU is another one we've
been losing a hundred and eighty billion
dollars a year for many years that's a
lot of money how much can you take out
of the piggy bank this will be more
important with you you or with Britain
well I don't want to say which I look I
think that I think that'd be I think we
have been with I guess would start off
by saying England's right yeah I ask for
as with England what's happening with
England they don't use it too much
anymore we talked about it was very
interesting but the United Kingdom is a
great incredible place it's an
incredible nation and it's you know been
one of our tremendous allies and another
one happens to be Australia he was here
also Scott he is fantastic in fact we're
honoring him in Australia at the White
House in a very short period of time but
but I think that excuse me at some point
that will yeah at some point that will
also Germany I'm gonna ask me to visit
German gonna be doing that too so I just
think they're very different and they're
going to be going at it for a little
while but ultimately probably it works
out they may have to get out they may
not make a deal the European Union is
very tough to make deals with very very
tough just ask Teresa names Thank You
mr. president a bill with Associated
Press that's hoping you could clarify
last year you left this summit in Canada
feuding with the summit host this year
things to me seem to be a little bit
different you're talking about unity hug
with Mack running the stage what it's
different and also as president macron
said he's passing you the baton now of
leading this multilateral institution
you ran on the platform of America first
what is your now now you have a mandate
for the International Committee of what
are you going to do with it well we
actually had a very good meeting I had
it out with one or two people where we
disagreed in terms of concept but we
actually had a pretty good meeting last
year I would say that this was a big
step above in terms of unity in terms of
agreement
we have really great agreements on a lot
of very important subjects but last year
was good also unless she was good also I
think less you might have been a little
bit underrated you know what you want to
do with it what would you what's your
agenda we're gonna do something
hopefully special we're gonna build on
what we have now we built on something
really good and we're gonna be going in
with some great unity if there was any
word for this particular meeting of
seven very important countries it was
unity I think most important of all we
got along great we got along good thank
you very much mr. president i'm ching-yi
chang with shanghai media group you just
mentioned that chinese vice premier Liu
her say China is willing to resolve this
issue through calm negotiation well I
didn't say he did yes yeah and will the
u.s. negotiate in the same manner yes
and also so the US will negotiate in the
same manner
absolutely great respect for China great
respect for the leadership of China
absolutely we'll put in to join next
year's summit I haven't said that but I
think that having President Putin in
what was the g8 it was a member of the
g8 and I heard he was a a good member of
the g8 having a man I think is more of
an advantage I think it's a positive for
the world I think it's a positive for
Russia I think it's a big positive for
Russia and it's something the group is
discussing they are discussing it but
just few hours people feel very much
like me many people what but this view
also go Russian foreign ministers saying
that it's not their foreign policy
pursue to return g8 what's your reaction
well you know we'll see I know one thing
if they were invited back I think they'd
be there if they weren't that's okay too
I just think they'd be
better inside than outside I mean as I
said before I really do I think there'd
be an asset I think it would be a good
thing you know some of the things we're
going in the room and yes sir in
particular we were discussing four or
five matters and Russia was literally
involved in all of those four or five
matters and a few other people looked up
and said you know why aren't they here
talking to us about it why don't we now
go home take it easy for a day although
I'm not doing that I don't think it easy
but we're gonna go home and start
calling them at the end of the week and
say hey how about this could have been
in the room we had numerous things that
we were discussing right numerous you
know a lot of things that we were
discussing and it would have been very
easy if Russia was in there he was in
the room we're gonna solve those things
now they're just in limbo but I have to
say with all of that very little little
info but somebody will speak um about
some things and frankly they're not very
complicated but it would be easier if
they were in the room thank you Josh go
ahead Josh mr. president there was a
significant talk at the summit about
climate change I know in the past you've
heard some skepticism of a science and
climate change what do you think the
world should be doing about climate
change do you still Harbor that
skepticism I feel that the United States
has tremendous wealth the wealth is
under its feet I've made that wealth
come alive we will soon be one of the we
will soon be export in fact we're
actually doing it now exporting but we
are now the number one energy producer
in the world and soon it will be by far
with a couple of pipelines that have not
been able to get approved for many many
years it'll have a huge impact I was
able to get Anwar in Alaska could be the
largest site in the world for oil and
gas I was able to get NY approve Ronald
Reagan wasn't able to do it nobody was
able to do it they've been trying to do
it since before Ronald Reagan I got it
approved with a number-one energy
producer in the world
soon it will be by far the number one
it's come in this wealth and LNG is
being sought after all over Europe and
all over the world and we have more
of it than anybody else and I'm not
gonna lose that wealth I'm not gonna
lose it on on dreams on windmills which
frankly aren't working too well I'm not
going to lose it so Josh in a in a
nutshell I want the cleanest water on
earth I want the cleanest air on earth
and that's what we're doing and I'm an
environmentalist yeah what people don't
understand that I have done more
environmental impact statements probably
than anybody that's I guess I can say
definitely because I've done many many
many of them more than anybody that's
ever been president or vice president or
anything even close to president and I
think I know more about the environment
than most people I want clean air I want
clean water
I want a wealthy country I want a
spectacular country with the jobs with
pensions with so many things and that's
what we're getting so I want to be very
careful do you at the same time at the
same time at the same time you weren't
called at the same time it's very
important to me very important to me we
have to maintain this incredible this
incredible place that we've all built
we've become a much richer country and
that's a good thing not a bad thing
because that great wealth allows us to
take care of people we can take care of
people that we couldn't have taken care
of in the past because of the great
wealth we can't let that wealth be taken
away clean air clean water thank you
very much everybody I appreciate it
thank you